Hey, Office Ladies listeners! Hello there! Happy holidays! We want to wish everyone a Merry Christmas, a happy holiday, and let you know that we are off this week and next. Yeah, guys. We want to hang out with our families, you know, get in some fun time with the kiddos, and we hope you're having a great time with your family as well.
I am going to attempt to make my very first panatone. Do you know what panatone is, Angela? Jenna, I don't know what that is. So you had mentioned it, so I googled it, and it looks like a very fancy bread? Yes, it is a spiced holiday bread. It has dried fruit in it. It takes about two days to make. Okay.
So a year ago on Christmas, I went to my friend Lindsay's house, and she served a panatone. Didn't you say Lindsay though? It's like always in like a ball gown, but always has amazing food. This is a very put-together person. Yes. She recommended that cleanse that I went on. She also serves amazing holiday bread. She's my goals, basically.
And this started me on my bread-making journey. It's my one-year anniversary of baking homemade bread. Even my bread-making teacher, Bonnie O'Hara, told me she will not make panatone because it's too difficult. She said she made it once, and she'll never make it again, but I am determined. I'm going to take it on. I'm going to make a panatone this year. So for the holidays, this is like our kids' wish list.
They want to see Star Wars. Okay. So we're going to go see Star Wars. They want to go to an escape room. Oh, they're so fun, Angela. Is it scary? No. Well, you have to pick the right one.
I don't want to scare it. This is like with our kids. I just want to be fun. They have some that are special for kids. Okay. You have to, I'll send you a link. Will you? Yes.
Okay, so they really want to do an escape room. And then Jenna, I'm glad you're sitting down because I'm going to make bread. What? Okay. You're going to make bread? I'm going to make bread because, okay. So our family came out at Thanksgiving. Josh's sister makes this rosemary bread from scratch.
It's so good. And she showed me how to do it. But as you know, I don't have a ton of patience with any kind of baking or crafting. And this takes like two days. And I don't, you're making a two day bread. I'm making a two day bread. And I'm making a two day bread. Lady.
And we didn't even plan it. We didn't. That's best friendship right there. Guys, we'll be back on January 8th with the fire. But if you can't get enough office ladies, head over to Stitcher Premium for our candy bag episodes. So this is where we answer more of your questions and we discuss all the things that you think we missed in our original podcast, which apparently is a lot.
Oh yeah. We get, we get like people writing in, but we're actually loving it because we're finding that it's opening up a whole new conversation for us. So go check out our candy bag because we really sort of dive into your questions. This week we answer some general fan questions and we play you the rest of our call with office prop master Phil Shea. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. And we will also have a special New Year's treat for you, so watch out for that in this
feed. Merry Christmas. Happy Holidays. Merry Christmas. And Birthday Christmas boy y'all. Bye. Bye now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.